[Music]
all these months all the time of marching
for my family for food for the
people
I will always always be in the streets
fighting for the freedom of my children
the violence the violence of the government and
the violence of the underworld
all those are reasons  for you to go out to
protest to demonstrate to defend your
rights and aspire to a better venezuela
[Music]
the former sports midfielder go if you write
foundry fibers there are many this opening
of washington and great depression in the
west where with three master's courses
of our labor interservice this
condition be sport world rochester
legal interests of equal sales of
control explains maribel words in her
selection on twitter team
[Music]
for you from apps elizabeth morales
tired of Spanish
[Music]
mons
in it for
a moment they voted good  being able to lend
to the country
was a peace for all
just snowballs moves from
sandwiches of an adventure axis
readers members
athens good  policemen give to the
termination constitutions hunger if the
material you know völkers marking the
saloon in a completely
cross country version and belen carmen corruption
in venezuela of the fair mechanical channel
opened spaces more on January 3 he hits
with three for youth the first goal of
kim at least present with entities
outside a new start-up venezuela
oil depends on each
blooming minister in three big slopes
by professor surfers problems for
this management transfer
live led system healthcare system
homework up bite
shot game ended up waking up
sexual at the time of living virginity
elitism orders ball xavi
I am to rectify fear of the hitn state is
that the ball is fast thinking about that
our independent where it was
precisely the programs or for
the boots are in the main forum
through seven verticals  at 60 and 70 the
third corner in the first event nor
fortin the biggest filter just ha  ppened
push-ups deserve me seinfeld de bourbon
sub-venues in urban soccer well and
work in america the veredita staff of
papers john lloyd you know metro far or
rectify doctor in software protest
is benefiting by icex can complex
consist of kicks but
internet satisfactions in bolivars
but  stable but even more friends
broken down to the straits really
must stagnate speak and best work
flash the good cathedral balls and
black market
s
[Music]
same
d
the lesson of the national
constituent assembly is an open fraud the
world  he sees it he has seen it it is clear
everyone is clear about what happened
now what we have to continue is to continue
looking for freedom because we
live in freedom and we know what that is
so here we go what happened
yesterday was the biggest fraud  that is
believed to have been committed in any
national election was a fraud sung
it was already known that it was going to be an election  ction
with little attendance but with a great
participation forged by the government
majors carmen steiner and television
carmen's fuel when bardem type
oxford and staff with futbolred for
experts power maximum number of this
type
international inc a supplier in action
argentina sold the delegation for the
panistas in santander the number you know
carmen heras both combine the same
[Music]
and